وفي احدث المواقف الدوليه بشان تفجير السد
قال البيت الابيض انه اراقب عن كثب
تداعيات تفجير السد في اوكرانيا مرجحا
سقوط عدد كبير من القتلى واكد ان واشنطن
تعمل على تقييم التقارير التي تتهم روسيا
بالوقوف وراء تفجير السد واشار الى انه من
المبكر معرفه تاثير الذي سيتركه هجوم السد
على ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا
ومعنى من البيت الابيض مراسله الجزيره وجد
وقف لاطلاعنا اكثر حول الموقف
الامريكي بخصوص تفجير اسد
نعم وسيله جونكر بملصق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن القومي قال ان
الاداره الامريكيه حتى الان لا تعلم من هي
الجهه المسؤوله عن تفجير السد ولكنه قال
ان السد كان تحت سيطره روسيا التي احتلته
بالقوه والتي ينبغي عليها مغادره الاراضي
الاوكرانيه كان واضحا البيت الابيض في ان
يدلي بتصريحات حذره جدا اجاها ازاءه الجهه
المتسببه بالتفجير وذلك بعدما نفى العام
الماضي جميع التقارير والتصريحات القادمه
من موسكو التي كانت تتهم اوكرانيا بتفجير
خط انابيب الغاز نور ستريم الذي كان يصل
الغاز الى المانيا كانت الاداره الامريكيه
صارمه جدا بنفها بان الاوكرانيين كان وراء
ذلك لكن بالامس كانت هناك تقارير اع
تحديدا من الواشنطن بوست نقلا عن وثائق
استخباراتيه ذكرت بان الولايات المتحده
كانت على علم بمخطط اوقراء السلطات
الاوكرانيه تفجير خط الانابيب قبل ثلاثه
اشهر من تنفيذ من تنفيذه سئل كريدي عن ذلك
وقال ان انه لن يعلق على محتوى تقرير
نقلته صحيفه ولم تتمكن من تحديد دقه
معلوماتها عن طريق مراجعه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه او التواصل معها ولكن واضح
وسيله بان الاداره الامريكيه حسب ما
قالكبير لا تعلم حتى الان من الذي كان قد
تسبب بتفجير السد اليوم ولكن رجح جون
كيربي بوقوع ضحايا من الاوكرانيين عدا عن
الاف الاوكرانيين الذين تم اجلائهم بسبب
الفيضانات
شكرا جزيلا لك وجدي وقفي مراسلتنا من
البيت الابيض